hey
what
I just want to take another look at you
it took no convincing on my part I mean
he came over to my house and it was
really from that first meeting yeah
really it's true it just was like a bomb
that went off and we're both
italian-americans so I was like uh
heating up all pasta from the night
before we were eating on the patio
talking about life and family and then
he wanted to sing with me
[Music]
I just stopped instantly in my tracks
and I said oh my gosh Bradley your voice
you can sing it comes from his gut it
comes from the inside of him it's one
thing to be talented and then to harness
that Talent I'm just so glad God gave
her the talent that she has and he chose
her because that's quite a vessel to go
through because it's really what you do
with it and she's such a beautiful human
being I mean he really fought for me and
you can have a hundred people in the
room that are watching you and 99 don't
believe in you and one does and that was
him